we are reacting to what is a woman what
is a woman
this has caused a bit of a stir this one
i thought it was you
know yeah
you said you changed your gender when
you were here last night this is this is
it well this is
i changed to you you chased me yeah now
we're here yeah i'm a man
as you can see
so um who do you know who this person is
this is apparently a a doctor who does
the change
the gender changes oh
yeah so
she's
quite well versed in changing
children
and adults into their
preferred gender she was such a children
that's messed up okay
my name is michelle forcier um and i
have a medical degree from university of
connecticut residency university of utah
pediatrics and i've worked for a number
of different planned parenthoods for 20
years i do advanced contraception and
abortion really quick smasher pass
hell no
i mean she's already worked for planned
parenthood so she's already like she's
already started off on the wrong floor
and for some reason i don't know why why
do these people always have like blue or
green hair i don't get it i don't
understand i think i could pull it off
no though don't you should i do it
that'll do it
don't do it i'm telling you i do not
know why
these
crazy leftists have green or blue hair
it's always the crazy ones i like don't
understand it let's see how crazy she is
okay
you know maybe she's a nice old lady we
don't know action as well as gender
hormones and sort of looking at the
whole sort of schema of gender sex and
reproductive
justice so you've done a lot of work in
this field could you just start by
telling us sure
at what age can a child first
begin to
transition into another gender or
identify themselves as
a gender different from how they were
born yeah well i mean there's there's
research and data that show that
babies and infants
understand differences in gender
some children figure out their gender
really early
and the reason why we are because the
fact that she tried to put in
babies and infants that's me this is
this is too sinister for me
i don't
like how would a baby know
she's saying there's research that says
that babies and infants know
you don't always say i don't need to see
a study to know that's not true
right like like it's just like people
take studies so out of context i don't
even know what she's talking about but
it's just common sense
but common sense isn't common with these
people that's the thing no
no it's not common like
anyway her hair we'll see okay question
how old's your son he's nine he's nine
do you think this month do you if if he
really wanted to change his gender what
would you do
at what age at this age yeah i would
tell him i would
i would explain a lot of things to him
um
as to why it doesn't make any sense yeah
do you know what i mean um
at some point in time my son wanted to
be sonic the hedgehog
because he loved sonic right when he was
like five he was like dad i want to be
sonic i want to be sonic and i'm like
yeah and so he used to run like sonic
everywhere we went it was a thing
should i turn my son into sonic the
hedgehog according to these people
no so as a father who is trying to guide
their child i will
guide him in the way i see fit do you
know what i mean i actually had a
conversation about this yesterday with
somebody and they were saying um
um
i hope your son is gay
because she's because we were talking
about like this and i was like why would
you hope my son is gay oh so you can be
uh less ignorant and i was like isn't it
funny that the left they wish death on
people they wish all kinds of things on
people and conservative people
like people who are just rolling with
common sense they don't do that no like
conservatives can have a debate and not
attack who you are
but the left like they immediately go
for your character i was doing public
interviews yesterday
oh my gosh and immediately they they go
for why would you do this do you hate
women i'm like i am a woman
i allegedly i guess i don't know i could
be a man i could be a man now
i could be a man be a man
the reason why we are say oh that's
interesting or important is because
they're figuring out their gender
identity is not necessarily congruent
with their sex assigned at birth when
the doctor sees the penis and says this
is a male
has a sex of male that's a arbitrary
distinction telling that family based on
that little penis
that your child is absolutely a hundred
percent male identified no matter what
else occurs in their life
that's
you think it's right you have to give
him some props because he knows she's
talking [ __ ] yeah and he's just like
i've gotta get this interview done the
lead attorney talks about how if
someone's being crazy you have to like
not let your face change
because like you want to let them keep
going yeah yeah yes yeah and hang
themselves basically yeah
he can't hide it
that's not correct so what is gender
affirmation care you're a big proponent
of if we walk through a child
is sitting down with you is questioning
yeah their gender what's the gender
affirmation process
affirmation means that as a pediatrician
as someone who says my job is to provide
the best medical care for you
is i need to listen really carefully and
how i put it in words for kids so that
they can understand it is tell me your
story
where have you been in terms of your
gender and your gender identity
how would your son respond to that tell
me your story he'd probably tell me a
story
he'd just be like all right so yesterday
i was with my friends and we were
playing football or whatever tell me
your story that's a that that's like
that's a
that's a statement you ask an adult you
don't ask a child that question well
cause they don't even know
like what are
i mean it's funny i haven't been around
like a ton of kids in a while because i
grew up but i grew up like around
because i have nine siblings you know so
there's always like a child in the house
and like the difference in your brain
between when you're 9 and 15 is like
crazy you're a completely different
person so how are they gonna have
someone make a decision at nine that
would have it would affect the rest of
their life um
and that's the thing you're allowed to
do something that can affect the rest of
your life at that age but you're not
allowed to smoke not allowed to drink oh
yeah
but you can change your whole gender
okay do you know what i was doing when i
was 10
going
i was obsessed with japan i wanted to be
japanese
you could have had um
you could have been transracial
i coulda yeah i was wearing kimonos
at the mall
and just like for fun because i thought
japan was going to do that language i i
didn't learn the language but i
memorized no i memorized some um
some what do you call it there's a
a movie that had some japanese in it and
i just memorized like the lines in the
movie and me and my friends would say it
back and forth to each other at the mall
kids
kids that's what kids do you could say i
was cool
i'm sure you thought you were cool no i
am i'm like so cool i was in terms of
your gender and your gender identity
where are you right now
and more excitingly where would you like
to be in the future
have you ever met a four-year-old
who believes in santa claus
says to someone who believes that
well fat man is traveling through the
sky and a flying reindeer at lightning
speed coming down his chimney with
presence
would you say that this is someone who
maybe has a tenuous grasp on reality
they have an appropriate four-year-old
handle in reality that's very real for
them agreed agreed but santa claus is
real for them but yeah santa claus is
not actually real
and but santa claus does deliver their
christmas presents
see
see
see